this is the image that the el salvador
government wants to transmit another
suspected gang member off the streets
his tattoos giving away his affiliation
to a criminal band
they've arrested more than 20 000 people
in the last month and a half as they
seek to clean the ms-13 and bury away
teen gangs out of neighborhoods they've
ruled for decades
but this also is an image of the
crackdown one of many women saying
goodbye to a husband or a son as they
disappear into the salvadordan prison
system here are others
i love you son she's saying
in march after a murder spike the
country declared a state of emergency
that meant people could be arrested
without a warrant the salvadoran
congress has extended that state of
emergency till late may police continue
to round up young men on mass
inevitably along with the guilty human
rights groups say the innocent have been
taken
mata andalus told al jazeera her sons
wanted the latter he sells face masks to
hospitals she says and helps her get by
now she's used a quarter of what she
makes in a month at a market stall to
try and free him
i don't know why the president is doing
this to innocent people people that
aren't guilty fine someone's done
something they should pay but the not
guilty
at least she knows where he is other
women are going from prison to prison
trying to find their relatives look at
the crowd here
and the crackdown goes on in the italia
district a well-known ms-13 stronghold
soldiers question and search everyone
going in and out
but an overwhelming number of
salvadorans approve of president naibu
kelly's actions
we have stopped paying extortion we're
not paying anything now the gang members
have been being seen they have
practically disappeared and business is
flowing
people are no longer afraid to come to
the city center and walk the streets
so many have suffered extortion rape
killing that even if some innocents have
to suffer others believe that's a price
worth paying if they can simply be free
the question is if at the end of all the
arrests confusion and brutality this
will actually work
john holman al jazeera